हेलो एवरीवन, इस वीडियो के अंदर मैं आपको
एक प्रोजेक्ट के बारे में बताने वाला हूं
जो कि है डॉकine। यह डॉकine जो प्रोजेक्ट
है उसको हम लोग प्रैक्टिकली यूज़ भी कर रहे
हैं इंटरनल काम के लिए और इस प्रोजेक्ट को
मैं आपको सिर्फ बताऊंगा नहीं कि भाई यह
प्रोजेक्ट है। ऐसे प्रोजेक्ट्स आप बना
सकते हो काम करने के लिए। ये प्रोजेक्ट
बहुत तगड़ा प्रोजेक्ट है। ऐसे प्रोजेक्ट्स
अगर आप बनाते हो ना तो आप की हायरिंग
चांसेस और इंटरव्यू में सेलेक्ट होने के
चांसेस बहुत ज्यादा बढ़ जाते हैं। ऐसे
प्रोजेक्ट्स आज के समय में एज अ प्रोडक्ट
भी काम कर सकते हैं। सो प्रोजेक्ट क्या है
वो हम लोग थोड़ी देर में बात करते हैं। बट
थोड़ा सा इसकीेंस समझ लेते हैं। ये
प्रोजेक्ट है डॉक माइंड। लेकिन इसके अंदर
जाने से पहले मैं आपको ये बताता हूं कि
आपको आजकल ऐसे प्रोजेक्ट्स बनाने हैं। और
अगर आप लोग कहोगे तो सिर्फ प्रोजेक्ट का
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन दिखाऊंगा, फीचर को
दिखाऊंगा। उसके साथ-साथ मैं आपको
प्रोजेक्ट को बना करके और सिखाऊंगा भी,
स्टेप बाय स्टेप पढ़ाऊंगा भी। बस आपको
क्या करना है? इस वीडियो पे लाइक ऐ जो है
वो 1000 लाइक का है। फटाफट कंप्लीट कराइए
और कमेंट एम है वो 100 कमेंट है। तो फटाफट
जितने भी लोग वीडियो देख रहे हो कमेंट
करिए इस वीडियो में। बस आप ये लिख दीजिए
डॉक माइंड। हम इसका ट्यूटोरियल स्टार्ट
करेंगे और स्टेप बाय स्टेप हम बनाएंगे इस
प्रोजेक्ट को। तो अब हम लोग क्या करते
हैं? प्रोजेक्ट को देखते हैं, समझते
हैं।ेंस इस प्रोजेक्ट की समझते हैं। और आज
के समय में यह ज्यादा कि इतना इंपॉर्टेंट
क्यों है यह भी समझते हैं। और अगर आप यह
प्रोजेक्ट बनाते हो या मैं आपको सिखाता
हूं बना के तो आप कौन-कौन सी टेक्नोलॉजी
सीखोगे भाई? कौन-कौन सी चीजें सीखोगे उस
पे थोड़ा सा नजर डालते हैं। ऐसे प्रोजेक्ट
बहुत ज्यादाेंट आज के समय होने वाले हैं।
हो सकता है दो तीन 4 साल 5 साल बाद ऐसे
प्रोजेक्ट इंपॉर्टेंट ना हो। बट हां
क्योंकि ये जो प्रोजेक्ट है वो एक एई
बेस्ड प्रोजेक्ट है। एi बेस्ड प्रोजेक्ट
है और एi ही नहीं इसके अंदर बहुत सारी
टेक्नोलॉजीस यूज़ हुई है जैसे रैग बहुत
सारी। ठीक है? आप मॉडल सिलेक्शन कैसे
करोगे? चंकिंग स्ट्रेटजीस कैसे करोगे?
बहुत सारी चीजें यूज़ हुई है। तो वो सब चीज
आप सीखने वाले हो। सो चलो भाई आप
प्रोजेक्ट देखते हैं। उसके बारे उसके बाद
में बाकी बची हुई बात करते हैं। सबसे पहले
प्रोजेक्ट को देखते हैं और प्रोजेक्ट को
देखते हैं। समझते हैं इसके फीचर्स को।
उसके बाद मैं आपको डिटेल में समझाता हूं
एक टेक्नोलॉजी के बारे में। क्योंकि भाई
आप टेक्निकल हो। मैं टेक्निकल हूं और यहां
पे टेक्नोलॉजी की बातें होती हैं। ठीक है?
सिर्फ टेक्नोलॉजी का ऊपर ऊपर नहीं हम
टेक्नोलॉजीस के अंदर भी घुसते हैं और
प्रोजेक्ट को डेवलप भी करते हैं। आपको मैं
समझाता हूं चीजें। सो अब आप यहां पे देखो
प्रोजेक्ट का जो नाम है दैट इज़ अ डॉक
माइंड। ठीक है? सो आप यहां पे देख सकते हो
डॉक माइंड प्रोजेक्ट का नाम है। एंड
टेक्नोलॉजी मैंने यहां पे लिख रखी है।
टेक्नोलॉजी इस वेरीेंट क्योंकि हम आप
टेक्निकल हो भाई। ऐसा नहीं कि सिर्फ हमें
फीचर दिखाना है क्लाइंट को तो शायद यह मैं
ना लिखता। बट कुछ ऐसी चीजें मैंने कर रखी
हैं जो आपको समझाने के लिए कर रखी हैं। अह
प्रोडक्ट जो हम लोग इंटरनली यूज़ कर रहे
हैं दैट इज़ अ डिफरेंट। अभी उसको लाइव में
यहां पे दिखा रहा हूं। बट ये देखो ये
प्रोजेक्ट जो है दैट इज़ एक्चुअली वर्किंग
ऑन लोकल हो। तो ये हमारा एक्चुअली
प्रोजेक्ट है। सो अभी हमने इसका यूज़ किया
है लाइक स्प्रिंग एआई यूज़ किया है बैक एंड
में फॉर द एi इंटीग्रेशन। एi को इंटीग्रेट
करने के लिए और एआई इंटीग्रेट ही नहीं
किया एआई के अंदर। लाइक एआई की बहुत अंदर
घुस के बहुत सारे इंटरनल फीचर्स हमने यूज़
किए हैं। तो यहां पे हम स्प्रिंग एआई यूज़
करेंगे फॉर द एआई इंटीग्रेशन पोस्ट ग्रेस
एसक्यूएल वेक्टर पीजी वेक्टर यूज़ करेंगे
फॉर लाइक वेक्टर्स। वेक्टर्स को रखने के
लिए एंबेडिंग्स को रखने के लिए। तो
वेक्टर्स का कह सकते हो पोस्ट गेस के अंदर
हम वेक्टर्स का सपोर्ट देने के लिए हम
यहां पीजी वेक्टर यूज़ कर रहे होंगे और ओपन
एआई एपीआई यूज़ कर रहे होंगे। बट ऐसा कुछ
नहीं कि आप सिर्फ ओपन एआई एपीआई का ही
सहारा लो। आपके पास बहुत सारी चीजें होती
हैं। ठीक है? तो ये मेजर टेक्नोलॉजीस हैं।
बाकी पहले की टेक्नोलॉजीस स्प्रिंग बूट
वगैरह तो है ही हमारे पास एमबीसी,
स्प्रिंग बूट ये सारी चीज़। ठीक है? सो अब
यहां पे नॉलेज बेस हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
हम एक्चुअली इस प्रोजेक्ट का मेन मोटो
गाइस यही है कि हम नॉलेज बेस प्रोवाइड कर
सकते हैं अपने चैटबॉट को। सो दिस इज़ आवर
चैटबॉट विंडो। हम यहां पर बहुत सारे
डॉक्यूमेंट्स अपलोड कर सकते हैं। ठीक है?
जैसे जैसे इसका नाम है डॉक माइंड। तो हम
यहां पे नॉलेज बेस दे सकते हैं। जैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल हमने यहां पे क्लिक किया। एंड
लेट्स सपोज़ हमें अ कुछ भी जैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल लेट्स गो टू सम थिंग लाइक हियर
एंड लाइक क्यूबनेट्स मास्टर क्लास में गए।
एंड यहां पे हम क्या करते हैं? लेट्स
प्रैक्टिस में देखते हैं। नहीं प्रैक्टिस
में नहीं है। ई बुक्स में देखते हैं। कोई
ई-बुक हम चैप्टर्स वाइज़ दे देते हैं। यहां
पे लेट्स सपोज़ कि हमारे पास चैप्टर वन है।
इंट्रोडक्शन टू द क्यूब्स। क्लिक करते
हैं। ओपन पे क्लिक करते हैं। आप देखो यहां
पे वेक्टर वेक्टराइजिंग एंड इंडेक्सिंग आप
देखोगे। और यहां पे देखो इंट्रोडक्शन टू द
क्यूबिट्स आ चुका है। अब हम क्या कर सकते
हैं? इन डॉक्यूमेंट्स से कुछ क्वेश्चंस
पूछ सकते हैं इस बॉट से और ये इन
डॉक्यूमेंट के आधार पे हमें आंसर देगा। तो
जैसे आपके पास बहुत सारा डॉक्यूमेंट है
पीडीएफ फॉर्मेट में, मार्क डाउन फॉर्मेट
में। तो आप डायरेक्टली यहां पे अपलोड कर
दीजिए अपनी वेबसाइट पे। डेटाबेस में सारी
इनफेशन स्टोर हो जाएंगी और फिर हम वहां पे
सिमिलरिटी सर्च के आधार पे डॉक्यूमेंट्स
से चैट कर सकते हैं। बेसिकली तो इट्स लाइक
कि हम अपना खुद का प्रोडक्ट यहां पे यूज़
कर रहे हैं। ठीक है? और बाकी जो फीचर्स आप
यहां देख सकते हो बहुत सारे फीचर्स हैं।
जैसे डॉक्यूमेंट हमने अपलोड किया वो सारे
फीचर डॉक्यूमेंट्स यहां पे आ चुके हैं। हम
पर्टिकुलरली स्पेसिफिक किसी डॉक्यूमेंट से
अगर सर्च करना चाहे तो हमने क्लिक किया
नहीं जैसे हम किसी डॉक्यूमेंट पे क्लिक
करते हैं। आप देखो यहां पे ये देखो हमने
क्लिक किया डॉकर बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस। तो आप
देखो यहां पे कॉन्टेक्स्ट में हमारा यह
वाला मार्कडाउन फाइल सेक्टेड है और यहां
पे भी स्कोप देखो आ गया और साथ-साथ में
यहां पे हमें देखने को मिल रहा है आस्क
अबाउट दिस लाइक इसके बारे में हम पूछ सकते
हैं और हमने कुछ टेंप्लेट्स बना के दिए
हैं जैसे हम क्या कह सकते हैं यहां पे
समराइज़ की पॉइंट्स पे क्लिक कर सकते हैं
और जैसे हम यहां पे समराइज़ की पॉइंट्स पे
क्लिक करेंगे आप देखोगे इट विल टेक टाइम
ठीक है अ एंड आप देखो यहां हमारे पास की
पॉइंट समराइज़ करके यहां पे आ चुका है इसको
थोड़ा और अच्छे से दिखा सकते हैं कि लाइक
आप यहां पे देख सकते हो कि अगर हमारे पास
मार्क डाउन फाइल है तो मार्कडाउन फाइल की
तरह दिखे हमने सिंपली ऐसे दिखा दिया ठीक
है यहां आप इससे कुछ पूछ सकते हो। व्हाट
आर द बेस्ट टॉप फाइव बेस्ट प्रैक्टिसेस अ
फॉर डॉकर। ठीक है? मैंने टॉप फाइव बेस्ट
प्रिक्सेस पे क्लिक किया। एंड आप देखो ये
टॉप फाइव बेस्ट प्रिक्सेस ये बता देगा।
ठीक है? अब मैंने इसको इतना फॉर्मेटेड वे
में यहां पे दिखाया नहीं। बट आप दिखा सकते
हो। आप जैसा चाहो वैसा आउटपुट दिखा सकते
हो। तो आप देखो यहां पे हमारे पास हियर आर
टॉप फाइव बेस्ट प्रिक्सेस बेस्ड ऑन द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट। पहला यूज़ अ मल्टीस्टेज
बिल्ड्स। अ दूसरा हमें यहां पे देखने को
मिल जाएगा चूज़ स्मॉल बेस इमेजज़ एंड दो के
बाद पांचवा मैं देखता हूं तो आप देखोगे ये
फोर्थ है यूटिलाइज़ डॉकर डॉकर इग्नोर
फाइल्स ठीक है एंड पांचवा ये रहा पास द
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन यूजिंग द एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल्स तो ये कहने का मतलब हमने यहां
से पूछ लिया अ सिर्फ यही नहीं आप ऑल
डॉक्यूमेंट्स पे क्लिक करके हमारे पास नो
डॉक्यूमेंट्स हैं। हम कॉन्टेक्स्ट इन नो
डॉक्यूमेंट से एक साथ बात कर सकते हैं।
ठीक है? बाकी तो आप बहुत सारी चीज़ कर सकते
हो। सपोज इफ यू वांट टू डिलीट समथिंग लाइक
लinक्स बेसिक हमें डिलीट करना है तो इस पे
क्लिक करके हम इनेशंस देख सकते हैं पहले
तो फिलहाल ये अभी देखते हैं। सपोज हमें
यहां पे डिलीट करना है सो हम इस पे क्लिक
करेंगे एंड क्लिक करेंगे तो हमारा वो वाला
फाइल डिलीट हो जाएगा और डेटाबेस में सारी
इनेशंस भी स्टोर जो थी वो भी डिलीट हो
जाएंगी। अब क्या-क्या इनफार्मेशन स्टोर है
वो भी हम थोड़ी देर में बात करते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लेकिन हम
यहां पे जैसे इंट्रोडक्शन टू द क्यूब्स
था। तो यहां पे आप देखो डिलीट करने के
साथ-साथ यहां पे इनेशन है। इस इनेशन पे
क्लिक करके बहुत सारी चीज़ आप देख सकते हो।
क्लिक किया मैंने। देखो यहां पे सारी
इनफेशन दी गई कि फाइल की साइज कितनी थी।
वेक्टर चंक्स कितने बने और चंक्स की
स्ट्रेटजीस वगैरह क्या होगी? जब हम इसका
बैक एंड डेवलप करेंगे तो मैं आपको
दिखाऊंगा वहां पे चंक्स की स्ट्रेटजीस
होती हैं। आप कैसे चक्स को डिवाइड करोगे?
कितनी स्ट्रेटजीस कैसे बनाओगे वो सब चीज़
आपको बताऊंगा। टोटल पेजेस हमारे पास एक
पेजेस हैं। अपलोड मैंने आज ही किया था। और
यहां पे चंक्स देखो। आपके चक्स भी यहां पे
दिख रहे हैं। प्रॉपर सारे जितने भी चंक्स
थे। आप डिलीट कर सकते हो। चैट विद दिस
डॉक्यूमेंट डायरेक्टली क्लिक करके यहां पे
आ सकते हो। अगर जरूरत नहीं है तो अगर चैट
को एक्सपोर्ट करना है तो आप चैट को
एक्सपोर्ट कर सकते हो। एमडी फाइल के अंदर
चैट आपकी एक्सपोर्ट हो जाएगी। क्लियर करके
आप चैट को क्लियर भी कर सकते हो। ठीक है?
तो इस तरह से आप सारा काम कर सकते हो।
बहुत सारी चीज़ यहां पे डायरेक्टली आप यहां
पे सर्च कर सकते हो किसी चंक से।
रिस्पों्ससेस दो तरीके से आप ले सकते हो
गाइस। आप स्ट्रीम टोकन पे क्लिक करोगे तो
जो आप मैसेज जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल हमें यहां
पे क्या करना है? लाइक इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चन
आंसर इनसाइट्स पे क्लिक करके जैसे किया तो
आप देखो यहां पे ये स्ट्रीम हो रहा है
डेटा। दिख रहा है? दिस इज़ अ स्ट्रीमिंग।
तो यह स्ट्रीम हो रहा है सारी इनेशन में।
बट अगर आप चाहते हो कि एक बार में ही हमें
डाटा मिले तो हम स्ट्रीम टोकन को ऑफ कर
देंगे तो हमें डाटा जो मिलेगा वो एक बार
में ही डाटा मिलेगा। ठीक है? सो दिस इज़
व्हाट बहुत सारी चीज़ आप कर सकते हो। इसके
अंदर हमने कुछ मैक्सिमम जो चीजें करके
दिखाई देन आप यहां पे क्लिक करके सारी
इनेशन देख सकते हो। एंड दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
कुछ शॉर्टकट्स मैंने बना रखे हैं। जैसे
हमने एंटर टू सेंड एंटर पे क्लिक करोगे
सेंड हो जाएगा। शिफ्ट एंटर टू न्यू लाइन
क्लिक कर सकते हो। एंड ठीक है? सो दिस इज़
द फ्रंट एंड एंड दिस एाई। दिस इज़ अ
प्रोजेक्ट। बट सिर्फ इतना बनाने के लिए
आपको बहुत सारे कांसेप्ट की जरूरत है और
इतने कांसेप्ट अगर आप खुद से कर लेते हो
ना तो आप एक मास्टर बन जाते हो एआई
इंजीनियरिंग में। ठीक है? क्योंकि ये एक
तरीके की एआई इंजीनियरिंग की है। सो मैं
आपको दिखाता हूं बैक एंड की कुछ चीजें चल
के। सबसे पहले आप देखो यहां पे स्वैगर
रिवाई पे देखोगे। दीज़ आर द डॉक्यूमेंट्स
या दीज़ आर द एपीआई जो हमने बनाई हैं।
सिर्फ एपीआई बनाई नहीं। ऐसा नहीं सिर्फ
गुड से एपीआई बना दिया। यहां पे
वेक्टराइजिंग के कॉन्सेप्ट्स यूज़ हुए हैं।
रैग के कॉन्सप्ट यूज़ हुए हैं। कॉन्टेक्स्ट
के कॉन्सप्ट बहुत सारे कॉन्सप्ट यूज़ हुए
हैं। तो आप देखो रैग और चैट से रिलेटेड
कुछ हमारे पास यहां पे
ठीक है? एपीआई हैं। देखो सबसे पहली जो
एपीआई है वो सिमिलरिटी है। परफॉर्म द
सेमेंटिंग सिमिलरिटी सर्च एंड ऑन स्टोर
डॉक्यूमेंट। तो यह सिमिलरिटी सर्च करता है
बेसिकली और यहां पे ये स्ट्रीम है। ठीक
है? क्वेश्चन आंसर कर सकते हैं स्ट्रीम
वाया एसएसई सर्वर साइड इवेंट्स के थ्रू। अ
क्वेरी आस्क क्वेश्चन अगेंस्ट ऑल द
डॉक्यूमेंट स्पेसिफ विद द साइटेशंस। तो
इसकी हेल्प से हम क्वेश्चंस पूछ सकते हैं।
और डॉक्यूमेंट मैनेजमेंट के लिए हमने यहां
पे डिलीट करने के लिए एक एपीआई बना रखी
है। अ सारे डॉक्यूमेंट्स क्रिएट कर सकते
हैं। इसकी हेल्प से डॉक्यूमेंट्स आईडी
सिंगल डॉक्यूमेंट क्रिएट कर सकते हैं।
अपलोड कर सकते हैं डॉक्यूमेंट को और मल्टी
अपलोड मल्टीपल कर सकते हैं। सो दिस इज़
व्हाट वी कैन डू। एंड यहां पे डायरेक्टली
यहां से भी आप यूज़ कर सकते हो। लाइक अगर
मैं ट्राई आउट पे क्लिक करूं। एंड सिंपली
अह अपलोड पे जाऊं और डायरेक्टली यहां से
मैं मॉनिटरिंग पे सपोज़ मैं गया एग्जीक्यूट
पे क्लिक किया तो हमारा डॉक्यूमेंट अपलोड
हो जाएगा। एंड हियर वी हियर यू विल सी द
रिस्पांस। सक्सेस ट्रू है। मैसेज है
डॉक्यूमेंट अपलोडेड एंड इंडेक्स
सक्सेसफुली एंड डॉक्यूमेंट से रिलेटेड
इनेशंस आपको मिल गई। यहां पे जॉब फ्रेंड
भी दिखा सकते हो एज़ नीडेड। अ ठीक है? आप
मल्टीपल फाइल एक साथ अपलोड कर सकते हो।
लेट्स सपोज़ मैं यहां पे गया एंड वी कैन
चेक अ मल्टीपल फाइल्स। ठीक है? आप आई थिंक
अपलोड मल्टीपल पे सेलेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है।
ठीक है? सो लेट्स सी। लेट्स सी लेट्स सी।
ठीक है? तो
ठीक है। सो
लेट्स गो टू द अगेन
चलते हैं हम यहां पे क्यूबनेट्स की दो
फाइलें मैं सेलेक्ट करने की कोशिश करूंगा।
सो लेट्स सी क्यूबनेट मास्टर क्लास एंड
यहां पे ई बुक्स चैप्टर्स पे आते हैं। एंड
अ दो सेलेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है। एक ही
सेलेक्ट हो रहा है। अच्छा यहां से हम ऐड
स्ट्रिंग आइटम यस एक्सैक्टली हम मल्टीपल
भी सेलेक्ट कर सकते हैं। कुछ ऐसे ठीक है?
सो हियर वी गो। करने के बाद सिंपली
एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे। एंड यू विल सी सारी
फाइलें हमारे पास यहां पे अपलोड हो
जाएंगी।
ठीक है? तो ये सारी फाइलें हमारे पास यहां
पे अपलोड हो गई और इंडेक्स भी हो गई। आप
फ्रंट एंड में जाके गाइस देख भी सकते हो
इस फाइल को। यहां पे अगर गया मैं यहां पे
और मैंने रिफ्रेश किया तो आप देखोगे हमारे
पास यहां पे 12 डॉक्यूमेंट्स हो चुके हैं
और डार्क मोड पे भी आप रखो कोई दिक्कत
वाली बात नहीं है। सो आई थिंक आपको समझ
में आ रहा होगा। सो दीज़ आर द एपीआई जो
हमने बनाई। अब एपीआई बनाना इतना आसान नहीं
है जितना आपको लग रहा होगा कि अच्छा सर ने
एपीआई तो बनाई है बट ऐसा नहीं है। अब आपको
मैं थोड़ा सा बैक एंड दिखाता हूं। ठीक है?
सो आप देखो यहां पे इसको बंद कर दो। ठीक
है? सो यहां पे यू विल सी लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स।
आप एआई की भी हेल्प ले सकते हो सारा काम
करने के लिए। बट अगर आप एआई के ऐप लेते हो
गाइस तो आप समझ नहीं पाओगे और समझ नहीं
पाओगे तो इंटरव्यू नहीं क्लियर होगा।
इंटरव्यू नहीं क्लियर होगा। इस आधार पे
ऐसे प्रोजेक्ट्स के आधार पे दूसरे
प्रोडक्ट्स आप नहीं बना पाओगे। समझे? तो
मेक श्योर कि आप चीजें समझो। मैंने
डॉक्यूमेंट करके यहां पे चीज़ रख दी है
डॉक्स वाले फोल्डर के अंदर। ये चीज़ भी
आपको दे दूंगा। आप वहां से जाके देख सकते
हो। बट बट बट मैं आपको दिखाता हूं टॉपिक्स
मास्टर में। देखो यहां पे आप कुछ चीजें
अगर देखते हो। सो लेट मी ज़ूम इट आउट। ठीक
है? तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हो मास्टर
सर्कल मास्टर। ठीक है? यहां पे आप देखो
मेन चार चीज़ इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स मास्टर इन
दिस प्रोजेक्ट। अगर आप ये प्रोजेक्ट करते
हो तो सबसे पहले स्प्रिंग क्या है इन
जनरेटिव रैग मास्टरिंग। अगर आप ये
प्रोजेक्ट अच्छे से करते हो तो आप ये वाला
चीज मास्टर कर लोगे। ठीक है? एंड दिस इज़
व्हाट अेंट। ठीक है? सो लेट मी शो समथिंग
मोर।
यहां पे आप देखो। ठीक है? ये वाली चीज।
दूसरी चीज़ अगर आप देखो यहां पे तो पोस्ट
केस एंड पीसी वेक्टर वेक्टर स्टोर। इस चीज
के बारे में आपको सारी इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस
अच्छे से समझ में आ जाएंगी और इसको फ्यूचर
में यूज़ कर पाओगे क्योंकि मैं आपको
बताऊंगा कि आप ई-कॉमर्स में आप एआई वगैरह
कैसे यूज़ कर सकते हो। आपको मैं बताऊंगा कि
ब्लॉग ऐप में कहां पे एआई यूज़ कर सकते हो।
सेेंटिक सर्च कैसे कर सकते हो। सिमिलरिटी
सर्च कैसे कर सकते हो। दीज़ आर देंट
एंटरप्राइज स्प्रिंग बूट थ्री एंड रिएक्ट।
अभी ये जो प्रोजेक्ट है मैंने थ्री पे
बनाया है। बट हम फोर का इस्तेमाल करेंगे।
कुछ चीजें फोर में आपको नहीं मिलेंगी। बट
हां हम लोग लेटेस्ट वर्जन का इस्तेमाल
करेंगे। ठीक है? डॉक्यूमेंट इंजेशन एंड
पाइपलाइन। ये सारी इनेशन आप बहुत डिटेल
में सीखोगे। और इसीलिए आपको ऐसे
प्रोजेक्ट्स बनाने चाहिए क्योंकि आपको
बहुत सारी चीजें समझ में आने वाली है भाई
ये प्रोजेक्ट करने पे। ठीक है? सो अब
सिर्फ इतना ही नहीं कि इसे ऊपर ऊपर आपने
टॉपिक सीख लिया काम हो गया। नहीं आप यहां
पे देखो स्प्रिंग एआई एंड जनरेटिव एआई
इंजीनियरिंग में आपको पूरा स्प्रिंग एआई
का इकोसिस्टम आप सीखोगे। ठीक है? अब
हालांकि वर्जनंस हमारा यहां पे जो आप
वर्जन यूज़ करोगे वो यूज़ करोगे। अभी के लिए
आप यहां पे जो चीज़ आप देखना हो कोर
एब्स्ट्रैक्शन चैटल रिट्री रैक के बारे
में आप सब चीज़ सीखोगे। रैक की अलग-अलग
स्ट्रेटजीज़ होती है भाई। देखो यहां पे रैक
की कौन-कौन सी स्ट्रेटजीज़ होती है? लेट
लेट्स सी। ओके गाइस। सो रैग में भी यहां
पे बहुत सारी चीजें होती हैं। आपको यहां
पर दिख रहा होगा कि रैग में सिर्फ रैग की
डेफिनेशन पढ़ लेना और ड्रैग की डेफिनेशन
अगर आप पढ़ते हो तो सिर्फ उसी से
प्रोजेक्ट आप नहीं बनाओगे। रैग में बहुत
सारी चीजें जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल देखो
डॉक्यूमेंट पार्सिंग, चंकिंग, एंबडिंग,
इंडेक्सिंग, रिट्रीबल, ऑर्गुममेंटेशन,
जनरेशन और यहां पे हेलुसिनेशन भी हो सकता
है। तो उस उसको प्रिवेंशन कैसे करेंगे?
उसकी स्ट्रेटजीज़ क्या होती हैं। ठीक है?
सोर्स एट्रिब्यूशन एंड साइटेशंस बहुत सारी
चीजें होती हैं। तो आपको ये चीजें मैं
आपको सिखाऊंगा डिटेल में आपको मैं
सिखाऊंगा। ठीक है? ओपन या इंटीग्रेशन कैसे
करते हैं अपने प्रोडक्ट के अंदर? कौन-कौन
से आप मॉडल्स इस्तेमाल कर सकते हो? नए
मॉडल्स, पुराने मॉडल उनकी स्ट्रेटजीस,
टोकन, ब्रेकडाउन, बजटिंग बहुत सारी चीज़
आपको मैं सिखाने वाला हूं। ठीक है? और
इतना चीज़ जब हो जाएगा, तो आपको यहां पे
देखो दूसरा जो पार्ट था वो था हमारा पोस्ट
केस, एसक्यूएल एंड वेक्टर, पीजी वेक्टर
डेटाबेसरी। इसके अंदर बेसिकली ये होता है
कि आप डेटाबेस के अंदर कैसे डेटा को स्टोर
करोगे वो आप सीखोगे। साथ-साथ में वेक्टर्स
क्या होती हैं? वेक्टर्स को कैसे मैनेज
करोगे बैक एंड के अंदर वो आप सीखोगे। तो
सीखने वाले तो बहुत सारी चीजें वो है यहां
पे। अब इसमें भी आप देखो तो देयर आर लॉट
ऑफ़ थिंग्स जैसे अ वेक्टर डेटाबेस एंड
रिलेशनल एनवायरमेंट्स। एप्रोक्स अ एनएन
जिसको बोलते हैं। एंड इंडेक्सिंग
एल्गोरिदम्स क्या होती हैं? अ जैसे हमारे
पास अलग-अलग एल्गोरिदम्स हैं। यहां पे आप
देखो HNSW हमारे पास एक है डिस्टेंस
मैट्रिससेस है। कोसाइन डिस्टेंस है। बहुत
सारी तरीके की चीजें होती हैं। तो हम कौन
सा यूज़ करेंगे और कौन सा कब आप यूज़ कर
सकते हो। ठीक है? आई विल टेल यू एवरीथिंग।
अ मेटा डाटा फिल्टरिंग एंड वेक्टर स्टोर
इंटीग्रिटी के बारे में आप सीखोगे। ठीक
है? अब इसके बारे में अभी हम डिटेल नहीं
आते। बट ये प्रोजेक्ट बनाते हो तो आप बहुत
सारी चीज़ सीखते हो। ठीक है? उसके बाद
स्प्रिंग बूट एंड जावा आर्किटेक्चर तो
आपने सीखा ही होगा अगर आप इस चैनल से जुड़े
हो। बट फिर भी अगर आप यार चाहते हो कि हम
एक फ्रेश सीरीज़ बनाएं। स्प्रिंग और
स्प्रिंग बूट पे लेटेस्ट वर्जन पे और
माइक्रो सर्विसेस पे तो आप कमेंट सेक्शन
में हमें बताइएगा। आप जिस चीज पे भी अ जिस
चीज की फ्री प्लेलिस्ट आप चाहते हो उसको
बताइएगा। जैसे अगर आप स्प्रिंग बूट चाहते
हो तो आप स्प्रिंग बूट कमेंट करिए। अगर आप
माइक्रो सर्फेस चाहते हो तो माइक्रो
सर्फेस भी कमेंट करिए। इस प्रोजेक्ट को
चाहते हो तो आप टॉक माइंड कमेंट करिए। जिस
चीज के ज्यादा कमेंट होंगे मैं सीरीज
स्टार्ट कर दूंगा जल्दी से जल्दी और डिटेल
में हम लोग समझेंगे एक-एक चीज अपने स्टाइल
अपने देसी स्टाइल में। ठीक है? नाउ
रिएक्टिव के बारे में मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा।
हालांकि रिएक्टिव प्रोग्रामिंग मैं आपको
ऑलरेडी सिखा चुका हूं। तो रिएक्टिव
स्ट्रीम्स एंड सर्वर साइड इवेंट्स के बारे
में मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा। क्योंकि रिएक्टिव
के ऊपर हमारे पास ऑलरेडी हमारे पास ऑलरेडी
सीरीज है रिएक्टिव की एट दिस वीडियो की
सीरीज़ आई थिंक बनाई थी। बट फिर भी हम
समझेंगे कि फ्लेक्स स्ट्रिंग क्या होती
है। ठीक है? ये सारी चीज़ क्या होती है।
ठीक है? क्लीन रेस्टफुल एपीआईआई डिज़ाइन
कैसे करेंगे? और एपीआई डॉक्यूमेंटेशन के
बारे में भी आपको मैं सिखाऊंगा। तो इतनी
चीजें आप सीखते हो भाई अगर आप एक
प्रोजेक्ट बनाते हो तो इन दैट केस। ठीक
है? उसके बाद आप देखो डॉक्यूमेंटेशन
इंजेशन इज़ वेरीेंट। डॉक्यूमेंट इंजेशन है,
चंकिंग मल्टीफॉर्मेट पारसेसिंग पार्सिंग
मल्टीफॉर्मेट मतलब कोई जरूरी नहीं आपका
डॉक्यूमेंट सिर्फ पीडीएफ हो। आपका
डॉक्यूमेंट टेक्स्ट भी हो सकता है। आपका
डॉक्यूमेंट मार्कडाउन फाइल भी हो सकती है।
आपका डॉक्यूमेंट तो यार कुछ भी हो सकता
है। सो देयर इज़ नथिंग लाइक कि सिर्फ
पीडीएफ से ही हमें क्या करना है? चंकिंग
करनी है। तो इन सारी स्ट्रेटजीज़ को आपको
समझना बहुत जरूरी है। साथ-साथ में टोकन
अवेयर चेकिंग स्ट्रेटजीज़ मल्टीफॉर्मेट
टोकन अवेयर चेकिंग स्ट्रेटजीज़ इज़ वेरीेंट।
तो मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा ओवरलैपिंग वगैरह
कैसे करोगे वो सब चीज़ मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा।
कितना ओवरलैपिंग होना चाहिए जब भी आप
चिंकिंग कर रहे हो। सो बाकी मल्टीडॉक
फॉर्मेटिंग में आप देखो यहां पे हम डॉक्स
फाइल अह यूज़ कर सकते हो। डॉक्स के बाद
लाइक टेक्स्ट एमडी एसवीजी पीडीएफ सब सारी
इनेशन देख सकते हो। ठीक है? डेवो्स डॉकर
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर इंजीनियरिंग इसके बारे
में भी डिटेल में बात नहीं करेंगे। बट फिर
भी थोड़ा बहुत मैं आपको बताऊंगा एक्चुअली।
एंड डॉकर कंपोज़ क्योंकि हम जो यूज़ करेंगे
अपना डॉकर कंपोज़ अपना जो डेटाबेस यूज़
करेंगे वो हम डॉकर कंपोज़ की मदद से यूज़
करेंगे। ठीक है? अ इन इट एसक्यूएल डेटाबेस
वगैरह को बनाने के लिए पोस्ट केक इनिशलाइज
करने के लिए और कैसे आप इनेबल करोगे
वेक्टर्स को ठीक है अ 12 फैक्टर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस अ में बेसिकली हम
एक्सटर्नलाइज़ करेंगे अपने कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस
को तो वो सब चीज़ तो आपको मैं सिखाऊंगा
सिखाऊंगा उसको मैं इतना फोकस नहीं करता
हूं मेनमेन इंपॉर्टेंट फोकस करता हूं।
इतनी चीजें जो आपको स्क्रीन पे दिख रही है
वो तो आप डिटेल में सीखोगे। हालांकि वी आर
थिंकिंग दैट यू टू यूज़ अ लेटेस्ट वर्जनंस।
ठीक है? तो हम यहां पे लेटेस्ट वर्जनंस का
इस्तेमाल कर रहे होंगे। लेट्स सी। अब आप
बताओ प्रोजेक्ट कैसा है और हमें ये सीरीज
स्टार्ट करनी चाहिए। दूसरी चीज आप बताओ कि
आप छोटी-छोटी वीडियोस चाहते हो प्लेलिस्ट
के अंदर कि लंबी-लंबी वीडियोस चाहते हो कि
एक कंप्लीट सिंगल वीडियो में पूरा
प्रोजेक्ट चाहते हो। बस आप कमेंट करिएगा
और लाइक एम जो है 1000 लाइक फटाफट कंप्लीट
कराइए। ऐसे प्रोजेक्ट्स के लिए एंटिटी
एक्सेप्शनंस। ठीक है? एंड अगर आपका सपोर्ट
रहता है तो ऐसे बहुत सारे प्रोजेक्ट्स हम
आपको फ्री में मिलाएंगे। ये हमारे
प्रीमियम बैच का प्रोजेक्ट है। सो लेट्स
डू दैट। लाइक करिए, सब्सक्राइब करिए।
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट वीडियो के अंदर।